ننتقل الان الى بيروت لنقل جانب من جنازه
نائب رئيس المكتب السياسي لحركه حماس صالح
الع ولك
الحمد
الله
[موسيقى]
اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن حمده ربنا ولك
الحمد
الله الله
[موسيقى]
اكبر
الله الله اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اذا مشاهدينا نحن في متابعه صلاه
العصر التي يعقبها مباشره صلاه الجنازه
على نائب رئيس حركه المقاومه الاسلاميه
حماس صلاح العاروري
والقياده بالحركه عزام الاقرع وكان العرور
قد استشهد مع سته اخرين في انفجارين وقع
بالضحيه الجنوبيه
ك
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين ولا عدوان الا على
الظالمين والصلاه
والسلام على امام
المجاهدين سيدنا
محمد وعلى اله واص هذه الطيبين
الطاهرين الاخوه الكرام الحاضرون
جميعا نجتمع اليوم
هنا في قلب العاصمه
بيروت لكي نبارك
لانفسنا بارتقاء
شهدائنا نحن لا نبكي
شهيدنا بل ان هذا هو غايه المنى ان نرتقي
شهداء في سبيل الله
على طريق القدس وعلى طريق
فلسطين فهنيئا لاخواننا
شهادتهم ونسال الله
سبحانه اهلهم
وذويهم وقبل ان اعطي
الكلمه لممثل سماحه مفتي الجمهوريه
اللبنانيه الشيخ عبد اللطيف دريان سماحه
امين الفتوى في الجمهوريه اللبنانيه الشيخ
امين الكردي اقول لكم اخواني جميعا
لئن انتقى اليوم الشيخ الشهيد صالح
العاروري
ورفيقيه فان في الامه الف والف والف رجل
كصالح
العاروري فليعلم ذلك العدو الاسرائيلي ان
الامه هذه امه
ولاده فيها الالاف الذين ينتظرون دورهم
على طريق القدس وعلى طريق فلسطين تبير
الله اكبر
تكبير الله اكبر
وم كل ابناء هذه الامه هم شارع شهاده من
اجل تحرير فلسطين وكل